it took me a while to finally get to the
primary source he's a guy that I call
alum beam and Alan beam in the book it's
a pseudonym it's not his real name
and I finally got him on the phone he
was terrified with good reason I mean he
was being hounded by attorneys for Boise
Schiller Flexner David Boies his law
firm which was representing fairness
they were so right as represented some
other colorful characters right and they
were trying to get him to delete emails
that he had sent to himself to his gmail
account trying to get him to sign an F
and affidavit on top of the
non-disclosure agreements he'd already
signed and he had hired a lawyer who
unfortunately wasn't very qualified for
this sort of situation and was giving
him that advice and he was really afraid
and so it took me a while to get him
comfortable and I granted him
confidentiality but promised to keep his
identity a secret on a technical basis
when you grant somebody like that and
I'm sure people who are not journalists
are curious as to how this works because
it does seem like a superpower like hey
I'm gonna give this person immunity how
do you know that person doesn't have an
axe to grind and is duping you to try to
get out of side of the story
what's the protection for a journalist
and then do you have to tell your
editors who the source is
and then does that open up more issues
right at work off-the-record sources ya
know these are these are good questions
I mean it's it's a gamble I would say on
the parts on the part of the reporter
and the source that it stays
confidential right because the source
doesn't necessarily know you and doesn't
know that you're necessarily that you're
a man of your word and and so you have
to explain to them you know like I do
often that I've been doing this for a
while and that I've dealt with
whistleblowers and confidential sources
many times during my career that I'm
always true to my word because you know
in my line of work you have to play the
long game if you burn one source then
your career is over and in fact this
second source is the one that tipped you
off yes a blog the well the pathology
blogger was the
first tip but then the the primary
source the source who was able to give
me information that was primary
information from which I could start
building my reporting was an ex
thoroughness employee and so he had to
trust me and and he made that gamble and
trusted me and I made the gamble that he
was who he said he was and that he had
had the job I mean I had obviously
research to verify something I looked
him up and everything and it all added
up and I knew that if I didn't get him
to talk to me then all I had were rumors
in innuendo and you know second and
third hand speculation you can't build a
story on that and so I made a quick
decision which was to grant him
anonymity and I promised to shield his
identity and then he started confiding
in me and unburdening himself and I
learned at that point in our first
conversation which lasted about an hour
that Thera nose had a device namely
Edison that actually handled only a
small fraction of the 250 blood tests on
its menu and that 200 about 240 of the
250 tests were done with just regular
commercial machines bought from
third-party manufacturers with one twist
which was that a lot of those other 240
tests were done on a one particular
Siemens machine that Thera nose had
hacked to uphold the myth that it could
test tiny sample blood pricked from a
thing even though the manufacturer said
no no right now one of the ways that
they hacked the machine adapted it to
small samples was to dilute the blood in
a saline solution to create more volume
because of course these commercial
machines were used to handling
regular-sized blood sample right so a
lot more volume and so to create more
volume to make the machine work they
diluted it and when you dilute the blood
that creates problems there's already a
dilution step in the Siemens Machines
protocols right a diluting dilution
you're double diluting you're diluting
the analytes that you're trying to
measure in the blood you're you're
making their concentrations so low by
diluting the blood that it's way below
even the analytical measurement range
that the FDA has
so you're using the machine in a way
that neither the manufacturer they
hacked an old machine that they should
not have done against the manufacturer's
warranty and they were deceptive and the
deception is just beginning
and the rest as a result the results
from that hacking are unreliable